面向数据的变态
听上去非常高高大上
那么在我们先讲db之前呢
我先跟大家简单的就是快速的过一下
就是说哎各种各样的编程的paradi
就是编程模式
比如说面向过程的编程对吧
面向对象的编程对吧
o那个o p我相信我们所有的同学学的最多的就是op了
对不对
那其实的话呢其实在我们在做游戏引擎的时候啊
我们各种编程范式都会用的
其实呃这也是我后来进入到游戏引擎这个行业的时候
我才意识到一件事情就是1000
我总觉得自己写代码还不错对吧
就凭着一点小聪明
我这个代码写的也挺好的
但是当你面对一个游戏引擎这么复杂的一个系统的时候
你会发现就是你不读书是不行的
真的游戏引擎真的要读书
就是说你要学各种各样的编程的pattern
就是design pattern
大家我记得以前有本书吗
特别好玩
就是那个封面上是个女孩儿
戴了个眼镜
老师这样盯你看叫什么
design pattern
教你各种比如说listener啊
什么这个机制啊
教你什么publisher
什么subscriber的这种pattern
你是面向过程的编程呢
你还是面向这个就是对象的编程呢对吧
这件事情其实对游戏引擎来讲是一个非常重要的一个
这个怎么说呢
你一开始要想清楚的一个问题
那么这里面的话呢
其实在早期的游戏引擎其实比较简单
比如说我们要做一个小乌龟的这个这个这个游戏的话对吧
小乌龟吃豆子的这个游戏
那其实很简单
就是他就是用面向过程就好了
一个函数对吧
我各种情况进来
我的数据做各种处理
我各种输入和输出其实非常的简单
但是呢其实我们一旦讲到这个现代游戏引擎的话
大家很天然的
大家学过的component的系统对吧
我跟大家讲了数据集成是不是跟数据集成一模一样
对不对
不好使啊对吧
我成为一个g o
我可以派生出各种各样的东西对吧
vehicle啊
飞机啊
武器啊
人呐什么都可以
万物皆goo嘛
对不对
那这个思想其实就是面向对象的思想
就是object oriented programming
这个思想其实非常的了不起啊
就是从它诞生至今的话
实际上它非常非常的符合我们人类对这个世界的认知
所以他去写代码的时候
其实你写起来会很舒服对吧
那么object orange orange programming
它是不是完美的呢
实际上今天呢我要开始去黑他了
你看这个我们为了都是我们的d o p就是面向数据编程
我们就开始开始狂黑我们的老朋友
这个op编程对吧
那o b编程它其实第一个问题是什么呢
他虽然理论上你会觉得很舒服
但是他有很多的r一系
举个例子
比如说我一个actor
他的战斗逻辑
你比如说这里面的这个怪物
它是一个actor对吧
那个人也是actor
他们俩都是g o
那我现在怪物这个人去攻击怪物的这件事情
我是把它写在这个
就是说人这个逻辑就是我去attack对吧
我去apply damage to
然后你们来传一个我我target的这个这个这个extra或者target的g o
还是说诶我被收集了
我这个这个这个就是说我这个龙
我说been damaged对吧
我被人打了
那我谁来打击我
谁来打我的
他给我造成多少伤害
其实你会发现就是虽然面向对象看起来对这个数据分析的非常的清楚
但是这个操作就这一个动作
他到底归属就是动作
在o里面就是一个function对吧
就比如大家想象一个目前对象的语言
你有很多的这个变量和这个这个类下面会有很多它的function
那个function就是动作
那这个动作到底是挂在这个这个这个在这个案例里面
是这个攻击者呢还是受益者呢
其实这是有2亿性的
而且不同的程序员它有不同的写法
大家如果打开一些游戏的这个逻辑的代码
比如说你们真的打开一个真正的商业级游戏的时候
你发现这种游戏它有很多的程序员一起写吗
你会发现有些程序员就喜欢从这个攻击者的角度去写对吧
有些程序员就喜欢从数据角度去写
然后两啊这个这就是this is real
这是真的这个这样的
所以这个时候你就很蛋疼
就是面向对象的时候
你就会发现哎呀这个代码的一致性强迫症患者又受不了了
对不对
那么第二个就是这个面向对象的一个很大的问题是什么呢
就是说它实际上是一个非常深的一个继承数对吧
那我现在假设我说我对一个东西造成了一个魔法伤害
我一层层的继承
其实我并不知道这个魔法伤害这件事情
你是在base class里面
比如说gu内层做的呢
还是在actor这一层
是所有的actor都能受到魔法伤害呢
还是说你在这个monster这一层去这个继承去做的
所有的monster受到魔法伤害
还是说派生出来说monster
你的这个flying呢
或者能变身的这个monster里面去
他能受到这个魔法伤害
大家想想看
是不是当你面对一个几百万行的这样的一个
真实的游戏引擎代码的时候
你现在这个时候当你产生了一个需求
你想了解这个事情是在哪个函数实现的时候
你在这个深不见底的这个这个继承数里面去找到这个函数的继承
这其实也是一件非常逗那个头疼的一件事情
而且就像我刚才讲的
就是它是具有很强的恶意性的
有的时候有的人觉得这个东西是个通用的需求
我要写到鸡肋去对吧
积累才是有道理的
有人觉得哎呀这个不行
这个是很特别的
我得把它写到派生类对吧
排序内派到最后也发现诶这个东西又是共用了
怎么办
我们把这个函数又移到它的积累里面去
其实如果大家去写这个就是o的这个程序员的话
这是我们的日常
我们经常会在这样的一个这个纠结
这到底属于这个叫基础服务还是属于特殊服务
这个问题上会纠结很久对吧
这个也是我们程序员之间的这个这个日常的对话
好
那还有o还有个什么问题呢
就是唉这个问题是我觉得也是很头疼的问题
就是这个base class就是鸡肋
会做的非常的繁复
这里面就讲一个案例吧
在这里我们就不黑了
是你某个引擎吧
某引擎的actor积累
大家有时间可以研究一下
你会发现就是说我的天呐
这个actor里面放了无数的功能
连迪巴克做这种功能在里面放了我
我当时第一次看到这个代码的时候
我就说我的天呐对吧
但是你仔细想想
如果我们在做一个真正的商业级游戏引擎的时候
你会发现你还真的是这样的
这里面就是会放很多很多功能
所以就是当我去写一个非常小的功能的时候
我派生是actor的时候
我会发现就是我本来只要你这么几个功能
结果你给了我一个全家桶对吧
这个大家想想这是不是一个商业销售的一个经典套路
其实在我们的程序员开发里面的话
我们有时候也会干这样的一件事情
所以其实这个base class的这个肮脏臃肿
实际上是oo的一个一个大型系统啊
o o做到大系统做到后来大概率会发生的问题
那么如果大家这个想一切身感受这件事情的话
可以打开任何一个商业引擎的源代码
大家就知道我在讲什么
ok那另外一个的话呢就是o还有一个很大的问题
就是性能其实很低
那为什么o的性能很低呢
因为其实o它非常符合我们人的直觉的数据的理解
对不对
但是大家发现没有这些数据啊
全部会分散到各个的这个object里面去
而且呢这个object通过派生继承它的数据全是异构的
然后他就每一个对象的创生对吧
allocate deallocate都是这个分散的进行
所以它在内存中啊
你们如果你们看一个oo系统的内存抓下来看的话
那真的就是东一块西一块
东一块西一块
那大家想想我们的cpu怎么去处理
是不是很疯狂对吧
很难受了
对不对是吧
所以它的内存是全是分散掉了
那么另外一个是什么呢
就o里面它是有这个类的这个函数的这个派生和继承对吧
其实很多函数会被重载
那么还有什么呢
虚函数对大家知道什么虚函数的概念
对不对
好啦
那就是虚函数是什么
全是指针
所以这段代码也是在内存中跳来跳去的
就是你本来这段execution的这段code是在一个地方
但是到另外一个执行到这块
突然跳到另一个地方执行另一个函数了
所以其实o的系统如果你用profile工具去看的时候
你会发现它的profiling是非常的
就是怎么说呢
非常丑的
这边是我们一个图了
大家看到这个图
你不管你懂不懂
这个就是这个高性能开发
你看到这个图基本上你就知道嗯
这个系统的性能做得不是很好
它非常的不稳定
所以其实欧有非常严重的这个性能的问题
那么第三个呢呃也就最后一个吧
就是o有一个更难的一个问题是可测试性
其实大家想象一下
就是说我们一个非常复杂的系统
你们有几百个上千个模块对吧
那我经常的每一个模块
比如说我要去测算这个啊
比如说角色的某一个业务或者是某个业务逻辑
比如伤害结算这个逻辑是不是对的
就是这个逻辑应该被人改
对不对
我要确保它的公式
最后的测试项全部都通过
那为了测试这个伤害的这个计算公式
我们需要干嘛呢
如果用oo写的系统的时候
我们需要把整个环境给创建起来
我们需要把这些这个所有的对象
所有的东西全部拿起来
然后呢我再去测试
中间呢有一个函数
对不对
因为我要把整个对象全部创建起来
但实际上呢在现代那个就是说软件工程里面
我们一般讲的概念叫unit test
他最理想的情况是什么
就是你一个庞大的code base对吧
你的代码可以一直改
但是我有比如说几十个上百个这种unit test
他只去测你的一个特定模块的数据
所以你为了测那个数据
你得把整个对象筛选出来
那么对象一层套一层一层套一层
到了之后你就很难把一个面向对象的这个世界里面的一个对
就是一个元素提取出来
对它单独进行测试
所以o的话你面对一个非常重度的oa系统的话
你对它进行这样的一个就是说unit test的话
这个代码其实是非常非常难写的
这也是欧啊传传统上有很大的一个问题
其实现在当然了
克服这个问题的话呢
方法不仅仅是这个就是面向数据编程
其实还有其他的方法
在今天呢我们不展开
比如说面向函数编程对吧
那其实也能解决这个问题
但为什么有这样的不同的编程的parade存在
其实跟这个也是有很深的关系的
特别是在这种超大型的软件工程
因为一个游戏引擎啊
真正的一个到达可以用的规模的话
一般都是几百万行以上的代码
那这个时候其实它的可测试性实际上要求也会非常的高
所以我们用前面大概十几节课
大概19节课给大家讲了
这个就是这个游戏引擎的架构
一直在用o的速度跟大家讲
诶
我今天为了卖我们的这个面向数据编程
你看我就狠狠的把我们的oo也黑了一遍对吧
这个真的真的就是这个我们这个叫叫什么叫喜新厌旧
我们都是大猪蹄子
看见好东西就把老就把这个新人胜旧人了
我们就把以前的小甜甜现在叫牛夫人了
好那接下来我们就看看我们的小甜甜长什么样啊
那其实呢我们的小甜甜叫什么呢
叫这个dorange programming
面向数据编程这个名字听上去就非常的高大上
确实是很高大上
那么它的基础原理是什么样的
就是说事实上就是现代的计算机的发展
我们会发现一个很有趣的一个一个特点
就是说我们的processor的速度其实是越来越快
但是呢我们的内存访问速度实际上增长的速度跟不上我们cpu速度
刚才就跟我前面讲了一个东西是矛盾啊
前面我讲哎呀这个cpu已经发展它它到它的这个瓶颈了
对不对
我们必须要多喝了
诶怎么现在你又去讲说哎cpu发展速度很快
把这个内存甩到后面去了
其实所有的东西都是相对的
这没有办法
就是说确实在过去的20年里面的话
我们的cpu是以将近上千倍吧
往下去讲
但是我们的内存访问速度呢大概也就提高了大概十倍左右
一个数量级左右
所以这两个之间的差距啊已经拉开了
将近是两个数量级以上了
2~3个数量级以上
所以这个实际上也是为什么就面向数据的
其实这里面直接导致了
就是说现在计算机里面有很复杂的这个叫cash的这个机制
其实在前面讲render的时候
给大家已经讲过这件事情了
对不对
那么这也直接导致了就是我们面向数据编程这个思想的产生好
那为了解决这个问题的话呢
其实在这个就是现代计算机架构里面的话呢
我们会做这样的一个叫cash机制
他你可以理解成就是他像个水泵一样的
就是说我们会cpu在最上面
那好靠近最靠近cpu的是我们的l e cash
那也是最快速开的cash
它能体量也比较小对吧
那么接下来的话呢就是我们的第二季cash叫l two cash
一般来讲是十兆左右
现在已经很难
我记得最早以前我买电脑的时候
只有两兆的l to cash
现在大家动不动可以买到十兆的l two cash
但是这个cash的话呢
它的速度大概比l e快慢一个数量级左右
好af cash是不是直接跟内存一打交道
其实没有
早前只有两层
但现在的话一般还会做l3 级的cash
它呢一般是在就是十几兆到上百兆左右吧之间
那么它呢实际上是比l two开始又去卖一个数量级
然后再到主内存
内存又慢一个数量级
所以它们之间依次是1000倍的差距
所以说当我cpu在进行处理的时候
无论是你的代码也好
还是你的数据也好
就通过这个cash
就像那个就是像那个什么叫分级水那个水泵一样的
一一磅一磅一磅的
把你的这个水就是我们的这个data从内存导到我的l3 l3
导到l2 l2 导弹l1
然后cpu才能对这个数据进行处理
那处理处理者诶发现数据没有了怎么办
哎那没办法了
现在l一找l一没有怎么办
问l r有没有r2 要有好
等一下你从l r调上来
如果l2 说唉我也没有怎么办
那好那不好意思
那就l3 掉
l3 是我也没有
那怎么办
不好意思了
那就从内存去掉了
那这样的话一路问完之后
当你决定要从内存中调数据的话
那基本上是1000倍以上的这个这个成本速度变得很慢
所以说今天我们在做整个高性能编程的时候
实际上这就是我们always keep in mind
就是脑子中一直有这个图
就是我们对这个cast是不friendly还是不friendly是吧
那么其实呢这就导致了就是当我们在写编程的时候
我们会非常讲究的一件事情
就是说我们的数据是具有locality
就是数据总是很紧的在一起
我对数据处理的时候尽量是一次性处理
哎大家这个概念是不是很熟悉
对的呀
因为我们在讲这个就是渲染的时候
讲到这个渲染如果要做得好
怎么能做得好
你必须要理解gpu是怎么工作的对吧
gpu里面有什么也有开始啊
对不对
他gpu里面那个他每一个那个rapper
那个每个rap对吧
每一个这个这个库塔核对吧
他也是要从各个cast里面去读数据的
这个数据的话它也有显存
那实际上的话呢就是说它也是需要就是保证这个数据尽可能的local
这样的话我的这个cpu才能疯狂的跑起来
才能读这个数据
那么这里面最简单的一个方法是什么呢
是s m d对吧
其实我们在讲render也已经讲过这个概念了
就是现代的这个cpu基本上全部实现了m i d
就是说你对一个四个vector啊
就四个这个float的加减乘除
你可以把它看成一个vector for
然后呢可以一个指令全部做完
它一次性会读四个内存的这个空间
而一次性写也是四个空间
所以当我们去packing这些data的时候
我们尽可能把它packing成这个a这个一个sm d的
比如16个bt的这样的一个一个空间
这个东西够不够呢
其实还不够
其实这里面今天给大家的就是这里面的话呢就是内存中的cash啊
它的数据是有一个管理的原则的
实际上这个你们原则的话最简单的做法就是什么呢
什么意思
就是说我的cash一旦满了之后
我会把那些不就是在最近一直用的东西
我会留住
把最不常用的东西
就最近最没有用的东西
我把它扔掉
其实是一个非常简单的一个调度算法
但这个算法的话呢实际上是一个经典算法了
但实际上还有一种算法是什么呢
叫随机的扔掉诶
大家会觉得你不是这个很合理的
是说在cash里面
我最近最近听来的东西
扔掉这个这个留在这儿
这个不长
那个就稍微远一点
不用的东西
那个留在那个扔掉
这不是一个正确的做法吗
那为什么你会采用随机呢
其实这是个概率的东西
就是说如果你的cash足够大
想象一下
比如说我有个将近1k或者一兆的时候
假设我每一个tick我随机扔掉
比如说64k64 个bt对吧
或者是128个bt
它相对于整个这个存储空间来讲的话
可能是1‰左右的这个地方
那你这样随机扔掉的一个基础是什么
是这个数据没有被访问到
你会发现就是说当你从概率去讨论那个去去讨论的时候
你会发现就是随机扔的策略
那么实际上就是说啊就是最近没被用到的数据
只要我被随机扔掉的话
实际上也符合了我们那个数学期望
就是说谁最久没被用到的东西
它有最大的概率会被扔掉对吧
所以其实呢这也是一个cash管理的机制
那这也是为什么我们在pc数据和代码的时候尽可能的放到一起
那这个时候呢我们要需要理解一个概念
就是说在内存中啊
我们去管理数据的时候
我们有个cast live概念
就是说一般来讲我们一次就是从这个比如说l2 l3 扔到l two
l two的l一的时候
我每次取的是一个cash line
就是大概是64个bt左右
就数据一个line
一个line的读写
实际上他这个讲起来就比较抽象了
就是说比如说我们看到一个我们第一个变量
一个是一一个
就是说呃integer对吧
我们定义了一个数字
其实啊他在cpu里面
如果它你对它进行计算的时候
他是不是在最顶级的cash
就l一里面有他的一段数字
有一段内存
对不对
它其实在l2 里面也有他的一段l3 里面也有一段
在内存中也有一段
而且呢是整个操作系统和cpu要保证应该是cpu
它要保证在这三个cash和memory的它的数据最终是一致的
而这些数据的读和写的操作其实呢是按照一个cash light进行的
什么意思
就是说我一次性去读这个64个bt的数据
我去对它进行赌的操作
如果这些数据发生改变了
我我要必须要写回主内存的时候
我也是一次性的一级一级地写下去
所以其实我们cpu在处理数据的时候
他是用csl的机制进行处理
那这样就会导致一个非常有意思的事情
就是说诶我们如果做一个array
做一个啊
不是array做一个取证吧
那我们怎么去读它和写它的效率高呢
其实这里面大家会发现就是同样的一个矩阵
如果你假设这个数据是按照这个一行一行的存储的对吧
那你逐行的去读它的话
你的效率可能比你拙劣的去读它的话要高个几百倍甚至上千倍
为什么呢
因为当你这个矩阵非常大的时候对吧
它在内存中连续的程序
但是你如果按照列取程序的话
你虽然只是往下移了一个y坐标
加了个一
但是他在cast line上可能跳过了很多次
然后他每一次要被迫的从my memory里面一层层的往上去放数据
所以这个时候它的效率其实是非常非常低的
所以这也是就是当我们去对数据进行访问的时候
它的order非常的重要
你要是按照这个order来
但这个具体在写代码的时候
大家就能有感觉
大家可以测一下
如果有兴趣可以去测一下这件事情
那么其实dorange的programming它的核心点是什么呢
就是他认为在游戏里面我的所有的这个事件发生的事情
所有事情的表达它都是数据
它也是一段数据
而这段代码和这个就是说数据放到一起
我核心关注的点是什么呢
就是说这个所有的这些东西在cpu中的话
我要把它的cash miss降得越低越好
这里面开什么miss
哎我这段代码执行完了
我要我要加载新的代码了
新的代码也会导致我的开始miss
就是这里面我给大家显示一个profile
就是说你会发现就是说导致了我们的时间消耗中
将近有7%的消耗是什么
就是我这段代码执行完了
我要被迫再去弄个新的一段代码
我有7%的性能损耗在这个地方
大家想象一下
这是不是远远的高于我们大家的想象
我们一直觉得啊数据的访问
数据的处理比较慢
其实人家代码的优化都是这个当你做高性能编程的时候
你要去思考的问题
所以说呢其实在这种面向数据编程的时候
我们会把数据和代码看成一个整体
而且我们尽可能的要保证数据和代码都尽可能紧密的
就是说在cash里面在一起
注意内存中他们可能分开
但是在cash里面我们要尽可能在一起
这样保证就这一段代码执行完之后
这些数据刚好能够处理完
接下来的话呢哎我们在swap下一批的数据和代码在一起
这就相当于是说我这件事物的处理者和我要处理的事物都是在一起
千万不要就是a就像这个打个比方
现在工厂里面啊
比如说我们要做一个斜的加工
我们还是继续鞋厂为例
那我们希望就是这个工人就能处理这些鞋的这个工人
和他的这个要处理的这个鞋的这些工艺
这些这些原料全部放在一起
这样的话呢他能一次性处理完之后
哎我再把这些这个工人和谐这个这些制成的东西全swap出去
然后呢我再换一个工人和他家处理的东西
这样的话我的效率就会非常高
那千万不要出现什么情况呢
就第一就是这个工人只能做一道工序
做到一半
你后面的工序需要另外一个功能来
你这个要切换工人
你要再从再从那个就是memory你把这个工人给调出来
对吧
那那我这些数据在这等这个工人了
还有一种情况是什么呢
就是说哎我工人是确实可以处理完这些鞋
但是呢这些鞋的原料四散在各个地方
我做到一半
我要从别的地方去掉原料
这两种情况都是面向数据的编程
很核心的想去avoid就想去避免的一种情况
他有的时候比你传统的o o的话高
就是一个到两个数量级是很正常的
大家听听这个数据是分开了
能快将近100倍
诶这个东西真的是不夸张的
就是说比如说像那个就是啊u体做过一个测试嘛
就是他用那个他的那个d o t s的系统做了同样的一个东西
大概能快到呃
差不多接近100倍以上
这也是就是你的这个系统和代码必须要这样去架构
才能有这样的一个能力好
那所以呢这个地方如果大家知道了这样一个基础知识之后
那第一点的话呢
诶我们在做这个任务的时候
我们尽量的避免就是说要对于他的执行顺序的这个order dependency
这个在前面其实讲的编辑时候跟大家讲过了对吧
就是尽可能让它之间order是无关的
那这样的一个无关为什么这么重要呢
因为很简单
就是说其实这里面有很重要的概念叫fourth sharing
什么意思呢
就是说我们有两个函数
他们在写一个
比如说读写一个变量
比如两个人再改一个变量
一个人在读
一个人在撇
但是如果这两个线程的任务
他们在写这个变量的时候啊
实际上它在内存中是在一个cash line
就是正好在64个bt里面的话
这个时候对于整个系统来讲负载特别大
为什么呢
系统你去读它的时候
它要这个要确保就是这个数据all the way到l一的那个cash对吧
你去改了它另外一个人去
比如说你去你去那个改了他另外一个人去读它的时候
或者两个人同时在写他的时候
他整个这个think和读的过程要专门的做两遍
才能让你的数据一致
所以呢当我们在写这样一个超高性能的这个系统的时候呢
我们会尽量避免两个线程会同时读写一个csline
这个地方就要求意味着就是说你不要把很碎的数据
就是同时让两个线程去访问
基本上就是一个线程访问的数据就是自己的这一块
双方尽量不要有任何的交集
否则的话你会发现就是说你觉得你没有做什么操作
而且你也保证了他们彼此之间写的地址是不一样
但是只是因为它的地址是在那个一个开始的范围里面
会导致整个这个内存swap的成本要高非常非常的多
那么第二件事情呢也是代码上
就是大家以前会经常不注意的一件事情
就是说我们在写代码的时候
我们今天会写什么呢
写if else对吧
if something else something
对不对
这个写起来非常的舒服
非常的逻辑清楚
但是其实在现在cpu里面啊
它实际上会做一个东西叫什么呢
叫branch prediction
就是我会预测这个branch对吧
哎这个人大家会觉得很奇怪
你凭什么预测我这个事情发生什么呢
但是呢没办法
就是cpu呢他为了追求极高的性能
因为他会发现就是说在很多时候
你100次进入到这样的一个判断的时候
可能有99次甚至100次走的都是上面那个branch对吧
可能是第101次会走到下一个branch
所以呢在实践中我们会发现就是branch prediction是个非常有效的
这样的一种方式去处理
那这样的话
但是它就意味着他会提前把那一端就是这个branch if着你们的
比如说这100行代码提前加载到我的这个l e的cash里面去
这样cpu可以直接去执行它
注意这里面就讲d o p的一个核心概念
就是说我们优化的不仅仅是数据啊
我们优化的还有代码
那么那这样的话呢
但是但是这时候如果你在下一次进来执行的时候
这个条件突然不满足的时候
诶这一段代码在l一开始里面他就无效了
他就他要被swap出去了
然后我再去调那个else的那个200行代码
它掉进来
那这个一调的话
如果很不幸的是
这段代码既不在什么l two cash
也不在l3 cash对吧
它是个冷代码
在在we meer里面的话
那就麻烦很大了
那这个系统就要等很久
所以说如果大家做个测试啊
你们去写用非常随机的数据去测这个就比较复杂的ef s的判断的时候
你会发现这个代码的性能就会非常非常的低
其实就是因为cpu他在做这个branch prediction的时候
就会这个产生很多的错误
那这件事情呢举个例子
就是说比如说这个函数非常简单对吧
说诶我从一到十
如果呢你这个中间中间这个这个这个a的这个数组里面的数字
假设大于十的时候
我就做第一种工作
如果不大于十
那我就做第二个工作
那其实你会发现就是他在前面走走走走
走到八也没有问题
但走到11的时候
第四个元素的时候他就错了
好他就他就那个那个branch prediction
那个系统
就cpu里面他就会说好
那我把下面那个else里的代码给调进来诶
但是呢做着做着就发现不对了
我靠这个你又小于十了
怎么办
哎我就把那个就是这个这个就是衣服那个代码也掉进来
这样来回倒腾的话
其实你的系统的性能就会下到非常的低
那这种情况你怎么办呢
其实呢有一个简单的方法对吧
答案就能想到了
那我能不能先对这个数据进行排个序呢对吧
排完序之后
那这样的话你可以看到这个血液里面
它只有在11的时候需要做一个切换
而后面的话就基本上全是els的代码
前面全是if的代码
那这个性能的话就是如果排序的时间不算进去的话
那假设你的这个读方式一方块二的话
其实是比较麻烦的话
那这个函数的性能它就会高于前面那个函数的性能
大家想想看
同样是逻辑的代码对吧
你的实现方式不讲效率就会变得非常大
那真正的在就是我们的就是说这个更高性能的要求的时候
一般来讲我们会提前的把这个数据分好
就是简单来讲就是说我们尽可能避免复杂的这个if和else
而我们一上来的话呢
会对数据
比如说我在创建每个数据的时候
我会加到不同的数据容器里面去
然后呢对于一个容器的处理
我只做一个逻辑
就是保证你的整个逻辑是高度一致性的
大家会觉得这件事情真的那么重要吗
但是如果你真的在写这种高性能代码
特别是高频的代码的时候
大家就会意识到这件事情对性能的影响真的非常大
特别是这个branch prediction的话
对于这个就是性能的store
因为那个时候你即使数据在cs里面也没有用了
为什么呢
因为它的代码要去swap
然后呢有的时候代码swap又会导致这个数据无效
所以是非常的麻烦
所以我们会非常就是鼓励大家
如果你在写这种高性性能的计算的时候
尽量的减少这种branch的运算也是这个道理好
那其实呢第二个呢就是说哎对于这种超高性能的
这种高性能的这种代码的开发的话
你的数据该怎么去摆发
其实刚才已经讲了一些基础的概念
就是说其实在memory的话
就是刚才讲的面向对象的话
它的数据就会通过各种各样的引用啊
指针啊
就是满天飞对吧
特别像现在很多同学已经不太接触
比如像c和c加加这种底层语言的时候
其实大家对一个对象
它在内存中的到底怎么放的
大家其实没有感觉的
我们都扔到各种各样的容器里面
对不对
容器里面什么功能都有什么反射啊
什么都有特别特别的方便
确实是这些代码写起来真的很方便
但是的话呢如果你要去写这种高性能的开发的时候
你还真的需要理解像汇编啊
像c语言这些底层的东西
那这个时候呢你去arrange你的memory的时候就要非常的讲究
这里面有两个很重要的概念
一个叫array of structure a
一个叫structure array this sa
听上去是不是很这个这个这个很高大上啊对吧
但其实他的想法非常的简单
就是大家想象一下
如果我们是用的这个oo的思想去定义或者一个定义一个结构
比如说一个particle
那它所有的属性是不是一个structure对吧
那我假设第比如说100个particle
你最自然的在内存中的这个数据排布是不是a第一个particle的position
velocity对吧
它的color
它的age对吧
接下来是第二个
第三个
第四个
这叫什么呢
叫array of structure
那这样的话当你对这个数据进行逻辑处理的时候
你会发现你需要没
比如说你你你做一个函数是要更新它的position的
你实际上是要读什么呢
它的velocity
它的position对吧
但是呢你为了读这两个数据
你每一个party的时候
你都要跳过去跳
因为你要跳过后面的color和edge
这样的话你的cash coherence就不够好
而当我要进行一种超高速的这种数据处理的时候
其实呢我们很多时候是把数据and structure array
就是同一个数据
我直接排成一个超长的r来进行处理
这个思想啊
其实大家再去看那个
其实大家真的理解现代高性能高性能编程啊
实际上有一个东西是特别类似的
就是大家理解一下
比如像那个好像computer shader
像在gpu上
为什么同样一个运算上了gpu对吧
上了显卡就变得非常的快
其实显卡他骨子里面就是一个以数据为驱动的这样编程
就是每一个shader你可以理解成是个函数啊
数据的话呢就非常紧致的
这样排不起来对吧
那其实的话当我们去arrange这个data的时候
一般来讲如果你想追求高性能的话
我们会按s a的方法去排除他所有的数据好
那接下来的话呢就如果大家懂得这个概念
就进入了大名鼎鼎的这个叫ecs系统
就是antity component system对吧
这个我相信如果对游戏引擎感兴趣的同学的话
对这几个概念就会耳熟能详
我我得首先道个歉
就是我不要首先我在这地方道个歉
就是说实话这节课讲的东西实际上是比较晦涩的
而且要求你有一定的这个开发的这个基础
而且很多概念它概念有很多
但是呢你哪一个他之间的关联不像大家想的那么紧密
它很难做到一环套上
为什么
就比如说最后我们讲的这个e c s系统的时候
它实际上就是前面那么多零散的概念
最后串在一起诶
大家提出了这样一个架构
就是说我们最开始去构建这样的一个游戏引擎的时候
我们会天然的想到就是我之前讲的component base的系统
对不对
用组件搭出一个我们想要的东西
那么这里面的话呢
你最自然的一种实现方式是用那个用oo的方式
你就会去构建很多的这样的一个一个对象
一层的派生继承
那显然它无论是它的代码是分散在各个那个就是类里面对吧
还有虚指虚函数只占一塌糊涂
另外一个他的数据也是非常的分散
所以这样的代码执行起来它的效率非常低
如果同学们尝试写过用oo方法实现的
component base的这样的一个机构系统的话
当你的机构里面confirm变得多
当你的肌肉变得多的时
候
你每一帧去tick它
你会发现它的性能比你想象的慢很多很多
有的时候你都很郁闷
你说我其实也没有做什么特别复杂的运算呢
那为什么我的系统性能这么慢呢
其实大家今天如果听懂了前面的第一个就是说就是cpu
它和内存和cash是怎么写作的
你就知道其实很多时候我们会浪费在非常无效的
就是cpu等指令加载
等数据加载对吧
执行到一半发现数据没有了
我又去找那个数据
然后数据值现在一半又发现我要调另外一个函数
这个函数是个虚指针
我要开始去找那个函数实现
然后找到那个函数之后
我要再把那段pc code再去加载
然后就这样来回倒腾
就搞得一塌糊涂
所以你可以认为这个工厂就是他没有人管理他所有的师傅
就凭自己的感觉去做
做了缺原料
我就去从库房拿原料
这个我我只会做了这个鞋底
我会做斜面
哎
我就去把这个鞋底的鞋面去递给另外一个做鞋面的师傅
然后大家去做
所以整个的这种就是说你可以认为整个任务的调度是完全无序的
所以这就是component base以及oo的导致了一个很大的问题
而ec s系统他就想彻底的解决这个方法
那他这个方法呢其实提出来之后
它的核心想法是这样的
第一对所有的我们的g o哎
我们叫什么呢
我们叫做entity antt呢
在我们的这个就是component base系统里面
它是个什么呢
哎它是一个类对吧
这个类里面可以装很多的component
对不对
那在这里面的话呢
nt t是非常非常的清亮
它就是一个i d i d指向了一组component
哎看这个我看到有点像
对不对
好
第二个就是它的组件组件呢在ec里面的话呢
实际上指的就是一个一组一块数据
比如说一个位移数据
一个速度数据这些数据
而这个component的话
实际上它没有任何的业务逻辑
注意啊
这个就和我们前面讲的这个component base这个系统不太一样了
因为以前我们讲每个component有什么有很多接口
对不对
有t k有什么get property啊
set property啊
一堆的这种函数诶
但是在ec里面这个是特别容易弄混的
就是说他的component是不允许有业务逻辑的
它就是数据纯数据对吧
你可以对他读
可以对他写
但是呢他本身并不知道自己的意义
而接下来有一个更抽象的概念叫system
system是什么呢
诶我来对这些component的进行处理
比如说我有一个比如说a moving system对吧
它会根据你的速度去改你的position
对不对
我有一个叫health system这个函数
它会根据你这个受到的这个damage
然后呢去调整你的health值等等等等
所以呢它实际上就是把数据全部打平
而且呢把这个数据从它的owner
从以前一个个的g o全部播出来
每一个每一类数据全集中在一起去存储对吧
然后呢但是呢每一个机他只是说啊我用了这个多少号的这个transform
我用了多少号的velocity
诶这个用这样一种非常离散的关系关联在一起
而对这些数据的处理是由sim进行进行的
而system他对数据的处理呢
它其实对着component的处理
它并不是一次只处理一个component
比如说我们前面在这个g o的这个component
这里面的话
其实component很多时候它是对自己的member数据进行处理
对不对
但是呢这里面有一个概念
大家一定要弄清楚
就是system呢很多时候它会同时处理好几类component的数据
因为这个他就是说因为我把这个单位拆得非常非常的细
所以ecs模型呢是一个大家提出的一个理论框架
就认为用这种模型的话构建的这种系统的话
他能够充分的利用就是这个这个数据的cash的这个那个coherence对吧
充分的压榨这个这个就是面向数据编程的这种性能
因为你可以发现这个system去处理的时候
它的它的操作是非常简单的
就是我很容易把system的计算分散到很多很多的和上面去
这也是ecs系统一个很大的一个优势
好这就是一个excel系统
大家听上去是不是有点晕了
很抽象了
对不对
确实啊这个概念其实是有点抽象了
但是呢你会发现它在实际中的话真的很有用
那怎么去解释这件事情呢
我当我在背这门课的时候
实际上是非常难的
因为我觉得就是说呃你前面的这些概念全部理解完之后呢
大概能知道我在讲什么
那带这东西的一个实际中的一个很好的应用是什么呢
哎我想到了一个帮手
就是我们把大名鼎鼎的unity的这个d o d o t s系统给搬出来对吧
unity呢提出了这个dorigin的text这个系统
那么这个系统的话呢
好像现在他们已经决定放弃了
但没关系
不妨碍我们这个去拿它来去分析一下
就是说esc系统的整个应用
你会发现就是说unity自己在讲说他的d u t s系统呢有三个支柱系统
第一个呢就是ec
它是重新的面向数据去组织它整个这个计算的这个框架
引擎的框架
第二个呢诶他有一个c sharp base的这个job system
为什么呢
因为我既然已经把数据变成这个component了
都要变成这个system了
那我就非常容易地把它b性化处理
我做了一个非常简单的josim
然后呢他还做了一个很有意思的东西
是什么呢
就是那个burst compiler
诶这个待会我会解释为什么他要重新做过confia这件事情
其实很很很很疯狂
就是你要还做过编译器
但是呢其实如果你想实现一个这么高的数据访问的这种那个效率
同时呢你要去实现这种quart这些机制的时候
其实你会发现就c sharp的原生的机制
它的效率是很低的
因为c 12 p本质上是跑在一个虚拟机上的
它并不是native code对吧
而break compiler他最可行干的事情是什么呢
把这个东西全部变成了native code
就是就是等价于汇编的代码了
所以说这在解决这个问题
所以说这三个系统在一起共同工作诶
它能实现了就是unity的d u t s的这样一个架构好
那我们简单的讲一下
就unity ecs它是怎么做的
首先第一个呢他也是把这个系统分成了无数个component
但是呢它在上面抽象了一个概念叫archittype
architeb
什么意思呢
就是你可以叫做啊原型或者叫泛型的概念吧
什么意思
就是说你会发现比如说我要做一个呃n p c
他所要用到的这个component
大概就这几个对吧
我想做一个就是说诶可以跟我战斗的这个这个怪物对吧
比如说monster它也是一个arc tap
它可能会多一些
比如攻击属性啊
做一些这种伤害属性啊
或者一些行为属性啊
比如说我在做一个比如说veo
它也有一些相应的这个components
所以其实你可以认为就是那个archetype就是什么呢
type of guo
就是这一类的g o
我叫做一个archite
那为什么他要做这个ark type呢
其实有个很大的原因
就是说当我游戏中有几百个上千个这样的entity的时候
每个nt底下面挂的component都是不一致的
对不对
那我这个system在处理这些ntt的时候
我不能一个一个的去找他们的
哎
你有没有这个component
对吧
你这component的这个我能不能用
那就这个问题很慢
但是我有archittype的时候
他就会让我这个就是处理的过程
就是我知道哪些entity我要处理的速度会变得很快
而且也方便别人去理解好
我有了这样一个ark type之后
诶
这张图是他最经典的一张图
就是说他首先把内存定义成了一个个的chk
然后呢他会把一类ark type的所有的component
按照他的component的类型唉放在这里面
就是一个个的去去放在里面
这样的好处是什么呢
你们会发现一个细节
第一就是说一个唱歌里面一定是同一类的
二黑
太对吧
那就意味着当我有个sim认为这个唱k我需要处理的时候
我只要去问这个唱歌的archive
比如说哦这是一个npc的archit好
我现在要做一个就是比如说对话的system
那我知道n p c这个tap里面有几个我需要的
come on呢
一定有
那我就对他进行处理
如果你这个是什么呢
哎你这个是一个就是载具的这个这个ark type好
那你这里面这几十个载具我是彻底不需要考虑的
因为我没有跟你对话的需求
那一个唱歌一般多大呢
就早期的架构里面一般它设成16k对吧
其实这个16k是主要是考虑到就是说cast line啊
考虑到这个l e l cash它是怎么去swap的
但是其实在现代计算机里面的话呢
这个一个唱歌的大小
我看了一下最新的一些资料里面的话
就是说这个唱歌好像变了大了那么一丢丢
具体的数据
我们团队他们好像上次看
我记得是像虚幻里面把它提到了128还或者是更大一点
这个具体数据大家可以去查
这个是你们可以调的这个量
那为什么他不是把所有的同类型的component的全放在一起呢
因为第一个如果我把所有的比如transform com的全放在一起
这些东西数据量就已经非常非常大了
它实际上也不符合我们的那个就是locality这样要求
而它实际上就希望这一段的sistent
这一段piece of code code
这个这个代码和他要处理的这一小块数据正好能塞进去
处理完
我再把整个的下一个system和他的唱歌part往里面一塞
除了外
这样的话它整个这个数据啊处理起来效率是最高的
这个其实是这个我觉得就是ecs系统是一个非常巧妙的一个地方
就是大家如果去写这个系统的时候
我是非常建议大家这么去干的
ok那其实这个时候呢系统就比较简单了对吧
比如说我们现在做一个就是这个我们的这个这个这个就是哎我往前去
这个move
我是update the position的系统呢非常简单
我只要拿到你的这个velocity的component和translation component
那我做一个运算
其实exist你可以理解成一个运算
怕算完之后这个唱唱你的所有的物体的这个translation的这边
这个这个component都会被更新一遍
因为你无论是毒啊
血啊
它都在一起
所以它基本上这个效率是非常非常高的
所以说unit也想说e s s系统的效率
就是刚才我讲了接近100倍的这个提升了
那这里面有个非常有意思的一个东西了
就是说那为什么就是哎我们这个unity要费那么大力气
去写一个burst的系统对吧
去做自己做个编译器呢
其实这里面有个很有意思的一个事情
就是说如果你整个这个系统它是用c hr去写的话
那这些无论你申请的一个array对吧
你申请你定义的一个数据结构
它实际上在硬件上到底对应的是个什么东西
完全是一个黑盒
它是跑在那个c sharp的虚拟机里面的对吧
大家想一下
在c 12里面
我定义一个变量
它根本就不是一个变量
它有很多的东西
它存储的数据只是很小的一块
它有很多反射数据对吧
但是如果你要写这么高高性能的
几乎和硬件一对一对抗的这种代码的话
实际上你最需要的是什么呢
你需要native的东西
所以在这个ecs里面的话
你看着你在去写c 12 p对吧
实际上你定义了一个array
你要明确的告诉他说
我必须要写native的这种container
实际上就很像我们c语言定义的一个真的就是一段裸指针
就分配了一段东西
那么的话呢这样的话它才能和内存中的memory 11的去对应起来
所以你对他的数据访问才是能够一一的连续的去去去映射起来
否则的话就是对于高级语言的话
他下面发生的事情基本上是不可控的
那么因为它是非常native了
哎你要加什么呢
你要加很多的安全的check
比如说像你写c sharp的时候
你不用去管这个内存的释放对吧
但是当你去写这样的一个
你就要非常花很多力气去考虑
就是他希望是在编译器层面
在job system层面去确保所有的这些logo的或者这些无用的资源会被释放掉
其实这件事情是非常非常困难的
所以呢这个时候他就会必须要写一个自己的compiler
那去把你的这个c sharc
arc的这个语言编译成其实非常底层的语言
并且并且完成必要的检查
所以其实我自己去理解这个就是那个dot系统
我觉得他做的其实是件蛮艰难的事情
就是说他希望把他的复杂度全部藏在自己的身上
对于这个上面的业务的开发者来讲的话
你不需要理解这么多复杂的这种cash啊
这种这种东西你只需要去按照我的这个follow去写一个c hr的一个东西
才能实现我想要的高性能
这里面就有个细节
就是说如果你想实现这种d u p的开发的话
如果你用c sharp的这个基础语法
你是很难写出来
分配啊
释放啊
你根本不知道它内存在什么地方
这些东西都变得非常的抽象和复杂
所以的话呢就是说unity它要实现这样一个d o t s的这个架构的时候
它就必须要实现自己的一个compiler
把你的c sharp其实他只用了c sharp这个语法
把它编译成了
就是它其实你相当于用c sharp语法
实现一个类似的这样的一个一个功能
所以这也是为什么就是他要写burst
就是我用burst的方法编译之后
这个性能又提高了很多倍对吧
所以这就是这个大家通过这个东西的话
大家就能理解
就是说为什么就是说呃我们去实现dot系统的话
它的难度有这么大
那么这也是因为他一开始用c sharp这个语言的
一个一个就是怎么说呢
一个弊端其实cp是个非常了不起的语言
我觉得是非常好的一个语言
但是的话在高性能开发的时候
他确实有这样的一个弊端
特别是做dop类型的开发
唉这一点就不得不提我们的另外一个很厉害的引擎
就是虚幻引擎了对吧
那我最近呢我因为备课嘛
我们就课程组织很有兴致的去研究了一下
那个arma 5的最新的那个max系统
大家想象一下最近rr 5最好的那个demo是什么刺客
那个什么刺客信条说错了
那个就是matrix reload
不是mhc reload吧
那个就是matrix那个demo对吧
在中间大家看到那个曼哈顿
对不对
中间有成千上万的汽车啊
行人啊这些东西
而max系统中呢哎实际上就是而要自己实现了一套就是类似于u s的
类似于job系统的这样一个东西
那么其实这个mac系统的话怎么说呢
我觉得其实也没什么好讲的
其实很像unity的d o t s
我甚至怀疑他们两个互相抄作业呀
但我就不去评论到底谁抄谁了对吧
那反正就是我看到的就是nt系统呢
它首先那个e c s系统里面
首先nt的概念
那t d里面的话呢
它也一样
也只是个i d
这里面的话每个i d呢它是有一个siri d
就是他那个单独永远往上ci number只是往上递增的这样一个东西
实际上就保证了这个i d永远不会就是被重用
其实有点像我们在之前跟大家教大家做憨豆的时候
你会有一个salt对吧
就保证你这个id可以被重用
但是你这个两个数字是不一样的
这是个小细节诶
我觉得它比较有意思的东西是什么呢
就是在max这个系统里面的话呢
它它的component叫什么呢
它叫fragment
哎我觉得这个词叫的特别好
为什么想象一下
如果我是写这个unreal的mac系统的人
我就很淡很头疼
因为我那边已经有1000多万行的代码
他在里面定义了无数的component
component
你现在告诉我说
因为我现在实现的是e c s的pattern
我这个东西也叫component
叫此component a非彼component对吧
而且我个人觉得component这个名字取得确实不好对吧
因为component会让我想起向下com啊
这些接口就你天然的会认为数据服务在一起的东西
但实际上在e s架构里面
component它就是purely的data
所以呢在这个max这个架构里面
它把它叫做什么呢
叫做fragment a
一小块内存的碎片
一小块数据诶
我觉得这个名字听上去就比较好
所以的话呢其实整个component的话
它实际上就是放了很多的这个fragment的这个数据
那么对于每一个这个nt来讲的话呢
哎我就会拥有这样的一些类型的这个这个这个那个fragments
诶
我觉得farm教堂很顺口
那第三个我觉得他做的我觉得蛮有意思的
订婚也就是说sim esim system对吧
system我刚才讲的它其实就是一个函数
它对着一堆这个component进行处理
他现在既然把抗风的变成了叫fragment
怎么办呢
诶他这个名字我觉得也处理的非常的好
他叫processor处理器
这个很贴切啊
就是说你给了我这么多数据放在这儿
对不对
我一个processor把你的数据全部处理完对吧
所以说其实max里面这两个几个秘密
我个人还是比较推崇的
而一个processor有两大核心功能
第一大功能是什么呢
我去query
就是说我需要对哪些满足我的nt对吧
它比如说我每一个这个processor
我需要多少种那个这个这个你的fragments或者多少种component
这component我到底是对你的读还是写
所以呢我先要做一件什么事情呢
我叫query
叫frankon query
那么他呢就会通过一段描述说诶
我对这个company我要去读这一类的component呢
我要去读这一类的这个这个component
我要去写
不好意思啊
这个我一会儿component
一一会儿fragment
大家都原谅我
因为确实特别容易混
但是他讲的是同一个东西
然后呢这个时候当我去对我的query
这就像写数据库一样的
我我先定义了一段数据库query函数
好
接下来一个query函数
一个query操作相机
我就把所有的这个mtt扫了一遍
把这些数据拿出来
那怎么去扫呢
其实在这个mass里面
他也用了archith这个概念
实际上他这种quy实际上会cash的
就是他上一次query完之后
这一次如果你没有变化的话
我基本上是不用动的
所以诶我就把所有的我所需要的这些这个archetype的
这些entity的这些fragment全部拿到
接下来干嘛呢
哎我去execute
大家去看他的excel那个代码其实也非常的简单
就是因为你做完了query之后
其实所有的这些fragment的全部我都拿到了
拿到之后呢
注意啊
这里面只是引用
他
并不是真的把这个数据搬过来
为什么他不需要把这个数据搬过来
因为对于每一类的ark type而言的话
它的数据全部也是集中存储在一个一个的唱片里面
所以说我对他进行处理的时候
我一个processor
我处理完这个唱歌之后
哎我接下来下一个依次切换的话
也是整个唱歌给切过去的
所以在这个时候它后面的处理就会相对比较简单一点
所以其实这就是这个max系统它的最底层的一个东西
这个东西的好处是什么
就是能够让我们在这个虚幻五中能看到那么庞大的一个曼哈顿对吧
陈陈应该是上千上万的这样的汽车啊
人物它其实就用这套系统来实现的
这也是一个c s系统的一个典型的应用案例
所以呢其实这里面我想多说一句啊
就是e s系统听上去非常的高大上对吧
因为很多同学们一直想让我们去讲一下esc
甚至大家会说诶小引擎里面我们也是不是实现一个e4
好像我们的引擎用了ecs对吧
用了这个dp就是非常了不起的一件事情
但是的话呢实际上我个人的理解啊
就是啊游戏其实是个非常复杂的一个东西
它里面的很多的业务其实非常的啊dependence非常的乱
也非常的复杂
几乎很难你把整个引擎变成e4 s的
这就是我一直在讲
就是同学们在学了这些前沿的知识的时候
很多时候我们会陷入到那种就是这个理想主义的这种冲动
就是诶我要搭一个彻底基于dp
彻底基于ecs的这样的一个下一代的游戏引擎
这件事情说起来非常的高大上
但是如果你真的作为一个实战型的这样的一个引擎的话
你会发现你所面临的问题和挑战绝对没有那么简单和抽象
所以的话呢其实ec的话呢对于引擎来讲
在有些单用的地方你就去用它非常的好
但是呢不单用的地方千万不要到处用
因为它会极大的增加你的代码的维护的复杂度
而且这种代码的开发起来难度也非常大
因为它确实是很抽象的
就是很多人天然的它就很难理解为什么数据和它的业务分开了
而且很多时候我们写一个业务逻辑都很下意识的就是数据
数据比数据c数据d对吧
我去问自己
问别人问一大堆
然后再说我东西怎么办
特别是大家如果写过真实的游戏逻辑的时候
你90%以上的逻辑都是这么写的
所以说ec系统一般会用在一些非常确定的情况下
比如说强如虚幻五的话
它的ecs也是放在了mass这个非常特别的这个案例里面
很彻底的用e s s的价格去做了一遍
它主体的引擎还是我们前面被我黑出翔的那个什么
就是面向对象的component pace的架构对吧
这里面我给大家解释一下
就是虽然我今天把这个o o黑的这个这个这个这个这个一无是处
但实际上这只是为了烘托气氛
为了抬出我们今天的主角d o p
那实际上的话呢就是说在一个实战型的游戏引擎里面的话
这两种架构是同等重要
甚至坦白的讲了
oo的重要性可能还是更还是大那么一点点
然后呢这个就是基于doo p啊
至于那个ecs这个系统的话
稍微小那么一点
这里面还有一个概念的话
我想给大家那个就是再去clarify一下
就是其实fiber base的这个job system的话
和这个e s s有关系
但是也没有那么直接的关系
其实这个fiber base的这个job system呢
它更多的是一种high level这种任务之间的调度
而ec呢更像是在一些大量的运算的时候
我是面向数据去组织我的预算
所以这两个之间是有交集的
但是呢他又不是完全的高度一致
所以说并不是说我用了这个就是这个e s s
我一定要实现fire的job system
其实你用 join的这个pattern一样可以运行得很好对吧
我就生成一个静态的graph的方法
能不能做能做
其实啊如果我没记错的话
就是unity的dot和阿荣耀的这个就是max system的话
它就不是一个完整的一个fiber base的这个job sim
实际上还是基于dependency graph构建了一个就是任务的fork出去
然后呢a回答说完再做下一件事
其实这个效果也是非常好的
没有任何问题
所以我还是那句话
就是做游戏引擎架构
千万不要执念这个一定要实事求是
就是你什么地方
关键是把你的技术用对好
那基本上讲到这儿
哎我们这节课的东西基本上讲完了
那么首先我给大家再去道个歉
就是说哎呀我觉得操作系统这门课第一个大学的时候我就没有学好
然后后来工作的时候
因为工作需要还认真的学了一下
但是今天我在讲这门课的时候
我突然发现就是给我的时间特别特别的少
所以像多线程啊
像那些这个比如说像这个这个mutex啊
像这些什么原子啊
tomic的这些东西到底是怎么回事
实际上今天没有深度的去讲
这个同学们如果深度对这线性感兴趣的话
可以花时间去钻研
你去理解这个job sim它的核心思想就差不多了
而且理解parallel programing它的挑战在哪里
dp也实际上dp实际上的话呢啊你真的去实现的时候
还是有很多细节需要注意的好
那今天讲了这么多之后
我说哎呀今天讲的东西我感觉特别的散
零零散散零零散散对吧
我怎么去总结我今天做的所有的事情
我后来想到了一个很有意思的东西
就是这张图
这张图啊
我觉得如果理解今天这节课讲的所有的东西
其实我们本质上讲的是一个高性能的编程
我们不会学的东西
因为我们更多的学的是怎么去表达一个业务逻辑
但是当你真的懂了怎么去编程之后
当你面对一个剧情系统
它又像游戏引擎这样对性能这么critic的要求的时候
其实你就被迫要理解操作系统和硬件
cpu memory cash是怎么协作的
而这张图的话呢
同学们如果有时间可以一行一行的看下去
你在这里面可以看到就是一个au指令到底花多少对吧
一个这个就是说硬件级别的中断
它到底要花多少
一个threat的contest swapping需要切多少对吧
比如说我们的一个c j i i里面一个函数调用一个虚函式调用对吧
一次站的这个swap你要花多少代价
其实今天我们讲的几乎所有的这个解决方案
它本质上就是对着这张图来优化的
所以同学们如果有志啊去做这个系统的架构师
对其实我个人一直认为就是说啊我们我们并不缺programmer
但是我们非常缺这个architecture
就是有至于进行这种底层这个系统架构的同学的话
那我认为就是说今天这节课讲的东西
是非常值得大家去深入研究和钻研的
而且你去钻研他的影子是什么呢
把这张图看完
每一行看明白
说诶为什么这个地方会更慢
为什么地方好像会慢
一就是大家看到这里的差别
不是说一个线性的
它是数量级的
就是十的零次方
一次方
二次方一直到十的多少次到四次方到五次方位
对不对
就会卖10万倍
甚至是个就是甚至是应该是最高是多少次方
我看一下十的四次方五存在对
最高到100万倍很可啊
100对100万倍
所以是挺挺吓人的
对不对
所以说一个系统如果写的不好的话
同样的逻辑
同样的代码真的慢个100倍是很正常的
所以这也是就是说啊就是说今天这节课想给大家讲讲的一个东西
就是说诶第一次让大家真的碰到影和
而引擎最内核的东西就是如何实现这种超高性能的编程
那么抓住这件事情的线索
也许是从这张图开始
那么你这张图看懂了
你再回过头来看我们课程前面讲的东西
其实就是自然而然就通了
ok那这就是我今天这节课的主要内容
那么还是再次感谢我们的课程组啊
就是大家其实这里面大部分的工作都是我们团队去做的
那我这个作为这个工具人负责把这些知识传递给大家
那么这里面的话呢
我们的课程组也分享了很多的资料
比如像cash系统到底是怎么work的
同学们可以看这些资料对吧
比如说那些各种的这个blocking的方法
nblocking的方法对吧
这里面有一系列的文章会告诉大家是怎么去做的
其实这里面有很多的paradise
我认为是很重要的
就是大家如果想去写一个b进化的程序的时候
千万千万不要土法炼钢
这个我是这个再次提醒大家
为什么呢
因为就是这是我们一直在做研发的一个一个一个观点
就是我认为太阳底下没新鲜事
我们自己拍脑袋想到的很多的解决方法
实际上别人可能在10年前
20年前
别人已经遇到无数次了
而且整个行业提炼和总结出来的这些paradim
就这些范式的话
实际上已经是几可以被理论证明是成功的一些东西
去follow他
千万不要发明创造
这是这是我觉得就是做大型软件系统的时候一个一个觉悟吧
那么接下来的话呢就是在游戏引擎里面诶
你怎么去做parallel的那个framework
也有以下的这些文献对吧
那还有什么呢
就是大家想心心念念的d o p面向数据编程也是有这样的一些文档
会告诉大家怎么去做研发
所以大家如果对今天讲的这几个两个高级话题的话
很感兴趣的话
尤其是如果特别是你自己已经是个从业者的话
我觉得这些文章很值得你去读
今天我们的reference的阵容是比较大的
确实今天我们的课程组准备的也是比较用力的
最近的话因为准备这个课程
我们把max系统又整个看了一遍
对吧对
所以的话呢非常感谢我们课程组的小伙伴们
那ok那今天就是我的内容的主体
最后的话同学们有什么问题啊
这个第一个问题是什么
把cpu跑满怎么办哦
我的天哪
这个问题实在是太硬核了吧
就是说如果自旋锁把cpu跑满
那这个其实我个人觉得就是可能还是你的任务的这个安排的不太合理
一般cpu跑满之后
你可能会触发一系列的这个
比如说那个你的县城对吧
可能是堵在那儿了
你那个县城可能要被迫swap出去
所以的话呢其实我们在很多时候尽量避免把cpu全部跑满
但实际上的话呢
如果cpu跑满之后
实际上很多地方很多的进程县城就会拥塞在那边
所以的话呃我我个人我至少我目前没有一个好的办法能解决它
我们比如像我们我们我们自己实现的是job system
那job system的话
它会一直会monitoring每一个核的它的占用情况
如果这个核占用使用率到过一个阈值
比如说超过80%到90的时候
我们就不会再给他塞任何的job
就是db会挂在那儿
但是我不会让他去启动
也就尽量避免这种跑满的情况
因为跑满之后的话
你的其实很多时候这个就是很多行为就会发生一些变化哇
这个问题也很难并行编程
有没有比较好的debug方法
对吧
呃实话实说
至少我首先的话不是一个非常好的并行编程的开发者
因为医院这真的是非常的难
那么并行编程的话呢
其实很多时候我们是通过什么呢
通过log的方法去抓他
就在log里面去抓
看到一些一些数据出现了问题的时候
我没有办法就疯狂的logo去看的
但是其实log有个很大的问题
就是说log本身在很多系统里面
它会就是说很慢
因为大家知道写那些文件速度是很慢的嘛
结果就导致了什么呢
导致了就是它的时序发生变化
所以其实在运行编程里面
比如说我举个例子
比如说我们在做那个fiber系统的时候
实际上我们会去做一个功能
就是说一键把这个fiber变成dance read
就是说把所有的job一次性依次按照dependent去执行
这样我先确保我的业务逻辑基本上是没有错的
如果我是发现我的业务逻辑
如果单线程执行是不会出问题的话
那我再去看是不是多线程出了问题
比如说那个时候我就可以猜测某些资源会经营就会怎么样
所以其实多线程编程它本身debug就非常的难
这也是为什么
就是说我们会建议就是在做引擎的这种parallel programing的时候
其实让尽可能少的程序员接触到多线程编程是一个正确的解法
就是说整个团队你们有几个技术最扎实
基础最扎实
而且思维最缜密的同学去把这个比如说带这个这个这个原子操作啊
待遇这种就是说这个锁啊这些机制的东西把它做完
做成一个底座
而它的上面的程序员
它尽可能地去简单的去开发这些逻辑
而且他所访问的数据
它能调用的函数都尽可能约束好
最好上面的同学只去写脚本就好了
他不用去关注下面真正发生的事情
这个其实也是就现代游戏引擎
因为你被迫要去支持这种多线程吗
那我会建议是这样的一个开发模式
否则的话就是说多线程开发到目前为止的话
第八个都是非常的困难
当然现在vc的话
新的一代的vc实际上这方面做的已经越来越好了
能让你看到很多状态
但是他最难的一件事情就是说有的时候你出现你出现你
你发现出现出了问题
你根本断不下来
你都不知道在哪个thread断下来
所以这个事情是很麻烦的一件事情
其实我们自己在写这样的一个就是job son的时候
其实啊我们的同学实际上在前期遇到了大量的就是非常非常难
第八个的一些问题
真的有一个问题出来之后
很可能会花一两个星期才能把它找到啊
第三卸载线程和逻辑线程的那个同步怎么做啊
这个其实怎么说呢
现在大家比较常见的方法就是这个诶我做一个ring buffer对吧
我的逻辑的啊
不是in buffer
就是我逻辑线程算完了
所有的值我一股脑扔给渲染
就是我一帧帧的
就是我相当于逻辑线程形成一个逻辑的friend
这个friend交给了渲染
渲染自己去做就好了
那么实际上的话呢就是这个地方实际上就会导致一个问题
这个问题就是我们现在经常讲到的
就是诶渲染线程总是比逻辑线程要慢一帧
因为他要等逻辑全部算完之后
然后这个数据才到渲染
这个目前的话呢大家也在探讨一些其他的可能的架构
就是说避免这样的问题
但至少目前为止啊
我觉得一个成熟的商业疫情
很多时候你还是被迫要让这个这个逻辑线上
现在要等逻辑限制全部算完之后
否则的话他的数据会产生很多的奇怪的二维性
因为当你dio vs这么复杂的一个系统的时候
有的时候我们必须要给他每个每一个就是每一类任务吧
有一个清晰的分界线
就像我前面讲的
就是如果你用固定线程法去这个区分游戏引擎的这个架构的时候
实际上这些这一类的任务
你不能够轻易地把它从渲染线程和逻辑线程啊
或者是那个防那个那个那个simulation
比如物理线程之间来回的跳
因为他之前做的这个事情是完全不一样
而且他很多时候的数据这样的一个依赖关系的
所以我们就讲了job system
job system虽然听上去很高大上
但实际上在真实的游戏引擎里面
你不太可能把整个引擎全部扔进job system
你可能只是把它部分的可能50%到60的workload
可以扔到那个job system里面去进行paralyzation
对物理呀
对啊
那么它实际上都是要做一些特殊的处理
才能够真的跑得很好
所以这也是一个非常难的一个问题
所以说我还是讲就是大家讲一个理论是很简单的
但是你真的面对一个引擎的实际情况的时候
你一般来讲你会对这个算法进行定制
就是为这个特殊的scenario去进行一些定制
好的好那个
那今天就先回答这几个问题
首先的话呢就跟大家讲
今天讲的东西确实是蛮硬核的
就是同学们的话千万不要好高骛远
先把引擎的基础东西做好
这个东西的话就是说诶如果后面有时间的话
我们尝试在我们的小应勤里面可以做一些小小样给大家
让大家感受一下
但这个这个flag不能立
因为这个有可能会导致那个小雨已经变得过于复杂
大家现在本来就看不懂了
但改完之后大家可能就更看不懂了对吧
ok好
那就是今天的课程
那我们谢谢大家
下一节课呢我们会去讲那个这个大家很期待的什么呢
哎lumen和nana对吧
这也是现在最前沿的渲染的两个技术
那同样的跟这节课一样
也是全面的
是高能
所以的话呢这个同学们这个做好这个被这个高能电到的准备
没关系对吧
我们都是一帮很勇敢的人好
那就是今天我课程的全部内容好
最后谢谢大家
我们两周之后见